It's my absolute
pleasure to introduce
Dr. Harlan Krumholz,
the Harold Hines, Jr.,
Professor of
Medicine and Director
of the Yale New Haven Hospital
Center for Outcomes Research
and Yale Center for Research
Computing Faculty Co-Director.
In addition to being
those directors,
he's also the Director of the
Robert Wood Johnson Clinical
Scholars Program at the
Yale School of Medicine.
His research focus
is on improving
patient outcomes, health
performance, and population
health.
Welcome, Harlan Krumholz.
I'm sorry because I
know how long he spent
working on that introduction.
You can post it online.
[AUDIO OUT]
Create the change for
society and science,
and also to do it so
generously, right?
So everything, you
heard from Brian,
is about this is white boarded.
I mean, you can put
your own insignia on it.
You can put this.
I mean, it's not
about what he's doing
for promoting
himself or his center
but it's about creating
the capabilities.
And then Aaron comes
along, and I just
have never seen so
much really courage
in someone of that position.
Because it's easy when
you've got tenure,
or it's easy at some points
in your career, where you're
in a secure position
to be espousing what
are the right things to do.
It's another thing when you are
in exactly the position that
makes it difficult to do
the right thing because all
the forces around
you are telling you,
you're not going to get credit.
You know, because this
is about your credit.
This is a time of your
life to be selfish.
This is the time of life you've
got to worry about yourself,
in terms of what you're going to
be credited with because that's
the way the career path goes.
And to have that voice,
I think that's what
makes your voice so
powerful because it shames
us all, really, in a way.
Because it makes
us realize, well,
what have we created
as an ecosystem that
says to people that they
have to worry that if they do
the right thing for society,
they do the right thing
in thinking about where
science needs to go,
that they might potentially
jeopardize their own positions.
Instead of thinking,
again, generously,
that if we all work
together in common cause--
that our contributions,
yeah, there
will need to be some
understanding of what
those contributions
are, but we don't
have to feel that we
have to hold tight
our data and our work and
do it to the detriment
of the progress that needs
to be made as a society.
So I just salute
you for all of that
and I think that it's something.
And then of course my
co-director, [INAUDIBLE]
showing all these amazing
things about the universe,
and you know, I want to be an
astrophysicist because I just
want to be able
to show that stuff
and say, you see this box here?
This box represents
the whole universe.
And this is what it was and
then these clumps you see?
That's what the universe is now.
In my second life,
I want to come back
if I had the ability
to be able to do that.
So this talk is a sort
of a basic orientation
to at least what some of
what my own journey was
and what I think
is important as we
think about this
issue of data sharing.
And I'd like to
enlist your thinking
about how do we actually
achieve what we want.
Now, I do want I have
some potential conflicts--
are we posting these slides?
No, but we'll post
them somewhere.
Again, this is a thing
where you go like this.
And now for some potential
conflicts of interest.
So these are the grants.
I'm on the Scientific Advisory
for UnitedHealth Care,
and I founded a
company that's trying
to enable people to acquire
their health related data
and to move it.
And we'll put this up
somewhere for people to see.
But I want to just get
to some terminology
because people get a
little confused when we're
talking about these issues.
And I'm just very--
this is just very simple basics.
That's the only way I
can really understand it,
which is we're often
talking about reporting.
When we're talking
about reporting,
the question is,
you've done something.
Have you told anybody about it?
And the one situation
I'm most interested in--
I'm a cardiologist.
I'm a physician.
If somebody's performed
experiments on people,
have they told anyone
what they found?
So there's this issue
of selective reporting
but there's also the
issue of who paid for it
and was there any return on it?
But then there's the
most important issue,
which is you put
some people at risk
or involve them and have you--
this is the very basic thing.
Does anyone just
know what you did?
Then the publication is
sort of the next level.
Is it available
anywhere more broadly?
Has it been subjected
to peer review?
And I think pre-prints are
a form of peer review also.
I mean, is it out there?
And then there's this
issue of sharing,
which is are you willing to let
people take a look at the data
and come to their
own conclusions?
And then Brian's bringing
up this other issue, which
I think is really important
that I've never even listed
on my slide because it's,
for us, it's always been
so far along, but
it's really are
you willing to share the
workflow, the underlying
stuff that led to the
data that you're sharing?
So for example, in
our field, there
may be that there's raw data
that needs to be adjudicated,
that ends up being one of the
data fields in the final data
set, but there's work underneath
that that actually might
be somewhat discretionary, might
not be just black and white,
and that often is
beyond the view.
Now, sometimes the FDA
or others get that data--
and I'm going to talk
about some of that--
through litigation, but
that's also another tier here,
which is is that it?
So my own journey
about this began
when I got involved in
the Vioxx litigation.
I have to admit, I was
totally oblivious to what
was going on with
Vioxx, and some lawyers
showed up to talk to me.
And I'd never been
involved in any legal cases
before, and at first, it
was like I really am not
that interested in
talking about this issue,
and I was busy enough and
it didn't seem like it
was going to be worth it.
Let's take this off.
But then they
started prevailing--
what they convinced me about--
this thing doesn't come off.
Did you ever make
a fool of yourself
when you're in front
of all these people?
All right, this thing is
just going to go like that.
So what they-- the reason
they prevailed on me--
the issue was Vioxx was a
drug that was to treat--
it was a second
generation nonsteroidal,
it's a COX-2 inhibitor.
Celebrex, Vioxx,
these are drugs that
were meant to be
safer on the stomach
and to have the same benefit
for, for example, joint pain.
And the thing was, they
told me that what they had
were all the internal emails
and communications and data that
was available within
Merck that had never
been shared externally.
And all of a sudden,
I mean, I never really
even thought about it
before, but it kind of
got me interested.
And I said, well,
I'll get involved
if you promise me
everything I touch can
go into the public domain,
because I don't think
that there's a wide appreciation
about the way science
is conducted, and I
think that there would
be something to learn here.
So I decided to get involved
with this for that reason.
And then we started
seeing emails like this.
I'll read it to you because I
know you can't quite see it,
but what this email says,
"memo regarding changes
to the Lane manuscript."
By the way, this guy's a
faculty member here now,
but he was at UCLA then.
But this is Merck discussing
this guy's manuscript.
And I'm OK with the
first two points.
Point three, "we can either
say this is 52% or 52%
and give the numbers that
you have in the table.
It's a matter of emphasis.
I'm trying to give this
the best face possible
that's compatible with
the truth of the data."
Now, let's give them the
benefit of the doubt.
I'm not saying they
were going to lie,
or I'm not saying that they
were going to corrupt the data.
But this is a very
important exchange
because it reveals something
that's actually, I believe,
universal.
I'm trying to give this
the best face possible
that's compatible
with the truth, quote,
unquote, of the data.
And I was telling Brian
when we were meeting
before, when I first
started on Vioxx,
I was really starting to
get upset with industry.
I said, well, god, this
is an industry issue.
But the deeper I got
into it, I realized
that this is a cultural
issue within science.
These people were sure they
knew what the truth was and were
trying to understand
how they could best
present their data to be
compatible with that truth.
"One can emphasize
what one wants.
It's not clear, from a clinical
perspective, what any of this
means for erosions."
These are the ulcers
in the stomach.
"So why not try for somewhat
better appearing message?"
And from point two, as Ned
and I were in agreement,
I would push back on this one.
"I'm surprised that GI adverse
events in a three-month trial
would not be of interest to
practicing gastroenterologists.
Why not try to take that out?"
But I'm actually not using
this to impugn Merck or even
this faculty member,
who was taped to say,
I'm glad to say whatever--
I said whatever Merck would say.
He was caught off
camera saying that.
But what I'm saying is,
this is a universal truth
within science.
People have strong feelings
about what they want.
They're trying to be
compatible with the truth
but there are multiple
interpretations.
And what I was
sort of discovering
was, that these guys
were just articulating.
We were able to see emails
that you wouldn't normally see.
And then you would
see emails like this.
They're talking about an
adjudication and a protocol.
So they're getting the records
and they're looking at them.
In this case, they were
sort of unblinded actually
to the results and they
said, "at this point,
I think it's too late to
reverse what's been done.
Deborah said that you told
her to count this as an MI.
I don't think the
adjudication committee
would have counted this as
an MI, blah, blah, blah.
I would prefer
unknown cause of death
so that we don't
raise concerns."
Now, again, I'm just saying
this is Merck saying.
The committee said
this is a heart attack.
The concern was Vioxx was
causing heart attacks.
This is in the Vioxx arm.
They're saying like, maybe
we should call it unknown.
It's a little bit on the
edge here of what it is.
Assume for a minute
they're right or wrong.
I'm just showing
you that there's
tremendous amount of
discretion at various points.
We're used to seeing papers as
sort of monolithic, pristine,
written in stone,
scientific contributions
and what it's not telling you
is the underlying uncertainty
around almost every
aspect of that paper.
Now, I'm not saying
that in the end
you wouldn't get consensus
around a lot of papers,
but I'm also saying
a lot of papers--
and Brian's shown
this very well--
if given to different
groups, they're going to come
to different
conclusions, in some ways
predicated on their
own cognitive bias,
their own beliefs.
And it's not an
evil/not evil situation.
I mean, in this case, the
cognitive bias can be strong
because there's also
strong profit motive,
but it's not just
the profit motive.
You're not going to get
promoted at that time in Merck
for raising questions
about a $10 billion a year
drug, or a $10 billion
over five years drug.
You're not going to
get into trouble--
you're not going get
promoted for that.
In the same way, I'm not
going to get promoted
in an academic institution if
I start writing papers that
impugn my great theory
for which I'm famous for
and start saying, you know,
all that stuff I've been saying
for the last five years?
I actually think
it's not true, right?
And again, it's not
maybe that you're
sitting in your office
saying, holy moly,
I gotta make this up,
but the way your eyes
are seeing the
data, the way you're
thinking about the framing
that you're putting on it
is because of your
deep set belief,
and now, you think you
know what the truth is,
and so you're interpreting
it in that way.
This was an interesting
figure that I saw,
which basically was looking at,
among the adjudicated events,
what percent--
this is now adjudicated
heart attacks.
What percent were confirmed?
And it turned out that they--
all things being
equal, you would
think they'd be confirmed
equally likely in the Vioxx
and the placebo group.
But it turns out that
the heart attacks
are confirmed more often
in the placebo group
than they were-- so what
this means is someone says,
I think there was
a heart attack.
Goes to the committee.
The committee says,
can you confirm
this was a heart attack?
Well, when you look at
it in the one group,
it's confirmed a lot more
often than the other group.
It happens to be the group that
favors the company's product
because if you confirm
heart attacks more
commonly in the placebo group
and you're throwing away
the ones that they're asking
about more in the Vioxx group,
Vioxx then has fewer
heart attacks than you
might expect otherwise.
Now, again, there are many
ways this can seep in.
Not just that someone at the top
is writing an email memo, hey,
make sure you favor Vioxx.
There's lots of ways it
gets communicated implicitly
into a bias that occurs.
So what we did was
we wrote a series
of papers based
on our experience
with this, that sort of
taught us a bunch of stuff.
We learned-- by the way,
we wrote a paper in JAMA
about guest authorship
and ghostwriting.
I mean, we discovered
through these emails
that there were a
whole lot of papers
out there that actually
academics never wrote at all.
And we had the contracts.
We saw the money
that was passed.
Basically, they
were given drafts.
They put their name on it, and
we listed them in this paper
and that made us very popular.
But we just thought
this was a case study
that we got to see some
of the underbelly of what
was going on in terms of this.
And we did another
paper in Annals,
where we learned that some of
the clinical trials that they
do are called seeding trials.
Have you ever heard of these?
So the seeding trial
is that they usually
are close to release,
and they said,
how are we going to get lots
of doctors using this drug?
Aready the FDA is on the thing.
It's not a pivotal trial.
It's not one the FDA is
going to use for approval.
And what they do is,
if you ever see a trial
where it seems like they
have a large number of sites
and a relatively small
number of people they're
enrolling at each site--
we saw the documents that
this trial won an award
in the marketing
division at Merck
because what their goal was
was to get as many doctors as
possible used to prescribing
the drug just at the time
it was going to be sold.
So they would go--
they can't even talk to the
doctors before it's out.
They can't begin to
start detailing them.
It's not available yet.
But if I've now got 1,000
practices, 1,000 doctors,
I can actually, at that
time, fly you to a resort
and give you days of
lectures about the drug
because you're now
part of a trial.
So I need to educate
you about what you're
going to be doing the
trial on, and you're
going to be getting your
patients on the drug
because you're in the trial,
and I can actually give you
a lot of support for this.
And then, you will be listed
in the authorship of some paper
somewhere.
And like I said, it
got a marking award.
It's a really brilliant thing.
But this is another
thing we learned.
I know this has nothing
do with open science,
but I just have to tell
you, this was amazing.
So the open science
part about this
was understanding the
underlying infrastructure.
What was the workflow of this?
How did they pick those sites?
What they did, though,
they picked people
that they thought were opinion
leaders and prescribers who
would get that experience.
We published in BMJ
a paper, and this
is what got us first thinking
about the data sharing issue.
So the Brits call learnt.
What have we learnt from Vioxx.
We didn't make that mistake.
I just want to make
sure you know that.
This paper was published
in the New England
Journal of Medicine, "Comparison
of Upper Gastrointestinal
Toxicity of Rofecoxib--"
which is Vioxx--
"and Naproxen in Patients
with Rheumatoid Arthritis."
This is a very
prominent study that
was very important in talking
about the use of Vioxx.
And they had an issue where
myocardial infarctions, heart
attacks, were a little bit
more common in the Vioxx group.
This was confirming
this suspicion
that Vioxx was going to be
a problem for the heart.
The writers write
that the incidence
of myocardial
infarction was lower
among patients in the naproxen
group-- that's like Aleve.
You see their framing, wasn't
higher in the Vioxx group.
It was lower in
the naproxen group.
But the issue was that there
was a borderline significance
about the cardiovascular harm.
But it turned out, when you
actually looked at the data--
when, in litigation, all
of the data became free.
We are able to examine it--
remember, Vioxx is thought
to be better for the stomach,
worse for the heart.
At the end of the
study, they stopped
counting heart attacks
before they stopped
counting stomach events.
So they kept counting
the stomach events,
and they got to it was
safer for the stomach.
But it was sort of borderline
for the heart attack.
So there were like three extra
heart attacks in the Vioxx
group that occurred within the
study period, but they said,
it was going to
take them too long.
So they stopped
three months earlier
counting the heart attacks.
You never would
know that looking.
Actually New England
Journal eventually writes--
and I don't know why
they didn't retract it--
but they wrote what they
called an expression of concern
that this had not been revealed
at the time of doing it.
But again, the only way
you can figure this out--
and they had a reason for it.
I can't remember.
The reason was something like--
It was a silly
reason because there
could be no reason for that.
But anyway, they start doing
it, and later on you could see,
when it was done the
right way, the rofecoxib
was much more harmful.
Meanwhile, what happens is the
company and a major academic--
first author's an academic--
produces meta-analysis.
They combine the data
that's out there.
But Konstam-- well,
it's up here--
is the first author.
Everyone else basically
is from Merck,
and they pulled the
meta-analysis together.
And we can see from
the emails, they're
the ones really
putting it together.
Marv does edit it.
He's a responsible
person, I think.
This is just what he saw.
But they are selective in
the trials that they do.
Not all the trials
were being reported.
So they were able to say,
here are the main trials
you should be looking at
for the meta-analysis.
It just wasn't that way.
And they end up saying,
when you compare
Vioxx, rofecoxib to
placebo, there's no--
in fact, if anything, there
might be a decreased risk.
But they cherry
picked the studies.
So we actually did
a pooled analysis.
Once we've finished
with the trial,
we had the judge give us all
the data on all the trials,
and most of these had never
been seen before because it
had never been published.
They just put out
the pivotal stuff.
And this is what I did
with my friend Joe Ross.
Joe was a Fellow at this time.
And we identified 30 randomized
placebo controlled trials
with 20,000 subjects,
15 from osteoarthritis,
six form rheumatoid
arthritis, three
is Alzheimer's, six others.
Most of them were pretty short.
18 were published of the 30
before the Vioxx withdrawal.
So we start looking at
them and we did this
as cumulative meta-analysis.
So we sort of start
adding up what
happens if you bring
in each trial given
when it was finished.
And you can see when
you first start,
you've only got one trial.
There's a 30% increase in
risk, but it's not significant.
And you start adding up.
By the time you
get to 2000, you've
got about a 2x increase
in risk and it's 0.07.
This is about the time
that vigor trial comes out,
that other one comes out, where
the relative risk was five.
And you start adding.
By 2001, you've got a
significant result in 1.35.
I don't know whether a p-value--
what it means at this point,
but the point is that
there's an indication
that there's a
possibility that there's
a risk that's becoming strong.
The drug doesn't get
withdrawn until 2004,
but the public
dialogue at this point
is this is an
absolutely safe drug.
And their own meta-analysis
is suggesting, if anything,
it could be protective.
And again, I don't want
to impugn the profession.
I don't want to impugn my
colleague Marv Konstam.
I'm telling you that
people start looking
at it in a certain frame.
I think the Merck people,
many of them good people,
are thinking about no
way this is a problem,
or somehow there's a
cognitive dissonance.
I've got to be very
careful around Brian using
any of these psychology
words, but he's kind enough
not to correct me.
But there's something going
on here that's leading to--
by the time you got to when
the drug was withdrawn, I mean,
the signal's just
getting stronger anyway
as more cases are accumulating.
But this is what kind of
got our group motivated
in thinking that
we've got a problem
in the scientific enterprise.
This lack of transparency,
the unwillingness
to admit that whoever's doing
the study might not be--
have the sort of the corner
on the interpretation
of that study.
That there may be
more than one way
to look at things and more
than one way to interpret them.
Got us thinking that we've
got a big problem here,
and this affects people's lives.
I'm just going to
say, there were
other studies like this where
this was an RCT of Celecoxib--
I'm sort of into the
coxibs right now.
But that led to
this study that was
in JAMA that
concluded that it was
much lower incidence of ulcers.
Main outcome incidence
of prospectively
defined symptomatic upper GI
ulcers and ulcer complications
and other things.
This was their main outcome.
We're better with Celebrex.
So this is what they
showed in the JAMA paper.
Look how much
better Celebrex is.
That's amazing.
But it turned out, they actually
had the 12-month data, too,
and the 12-month data, it
looks a lot less impressive.
But they just had
decided, why show a year?
We've got six months.
So but again, this
is about this stuff
can't happen if we're
starting to share data.
It's out there.
I mean, there's
nothing in it that's
for anyone who's
going to try to do it.
And if someone did
feel like six months
was somehow telling you
something important,
let them make the case.
But these are the kind of
things that's come out.
You may have seen this one
more recently with Paxil.
This was a study that was
published more than a decade
ago that was
suggesting that Paxil
was more effective in
reducing depressive symptoms.
And they reported side effects,
but they were basically saying,
serious side effects
in the Paxil group,
in imipramine group, five,
and two in the placebo group.
But then there's
this effort to say,
let's really take a second
look at some of these trials.
Recently the BMJ publishes this
thing, "Restoring Study 329,
Efficacy and Harms of
Paroxetine and Imipramine
in Treatment of Major
Depression in Adolescents."
This study ends up saying
efficacy re-analysis, according
to the way that
they did it, doesn't
look like it's
any better, but it
does look like it's associated
with suicidal and self-injury
events.
There's a lot of
concern now, that people
were being prescribed Paxil,
especially adolescents, to try
to treat depression but
actually was raising
the risk of suicidality.
The point I'm making--
and I don't want to get
into the details
of how this is--
but it's just the point that
different groups can see
the same data, even trial data.
What I've learned to discover
is that people have this idea
that it's so
formulaic in a trial,
that you can give
anyone the same data
and they're going to come
up with the same answer.
And any questioning
of that is again,
sort of criticizing the
integrity of the investigators.
And I'm trying to
take all that out.
I am not criticizing either
those earlier or the late.
I'm just suggesting
the possibility
that even well-intentioned
people will
come to different
conclusions and again, this
is what Brian's showing
time and time again now
in the reproducibility studies.
You don't have to think
that it's about bad actors.
I think the moment you
worry about bad actors is
when you begin to
trivialize this problem,
because then it just becomes
about the people who don't have
good morals, the people who
are just seeking their own self
benefit, and if we can
just identify those people
and get them out because
it's just like racism.
It's just like
racism, I guess, which
is like, let's get rid of
the personalized racism
but we neglect the
structural racism.
It's just like saying,
because it can't be me.
I can't be caught up in this
because I'm not like that.
And just like racism,
I'm not like that,
but the truth is, we're talking
about something that pervades
the human experience, this
cognitive bias in this case,
the way in which people think
about race and differences
and tribalism in another case.
These are things
that we have to begin
to say are not sequestered to
a few bad actors but in fact,
are affecting the entire
scientific enterprise.
I believe that the transparency,
the willingness to be,
the sharing is the most
important treatment
of that problem in science.
Because it begins to open
our minds to the idea-- now,
I will tell you, on
things like this,
what I hear from
people is, I don't
want to share my data because
there are people who disagree
with me, who are agenda driven,
who are going to take my data,
and then they're going
to do bad things with it.
What are the bad things?
They're going to
produce something
that disagrees with me.
What's implicit in that?
I don't have an agenda.
I don't have a point of view.
I haven't done that same thing.
And in my field, a lot of
the people running trials
are people who have a deep
seated belief in the value
of a particular treatment.
They wouldn't even be
the head of the trial
if they didn't, in
their hearts, say,
this could be something that
could be successful for people.
We somehow don't have a
machine, where somebody
thinks this is important.
I want to find you, who don't
have an opinion about it,
to study it.
We tend to find people to
study it who are enthusiasts.
And that's what, by the
way, gives them the energy
to recruit the sites and
bring people on board
and there are lots
of things about that.
Then they go on
a tour afterwards
and tell people why it's such
a success if it's successful.
The companies who
are paying for it
want people like that, not
necessarily because they
want people who are going
to corrupt the trial,
but they want someone
who can cheerlead
if this thing's positive.
They want opinion leaders.
They want people who actually
are excited about this idea,
because they want the
translation if they
get the positive effect.
But what we have to begin to
realize is we all have agendas.
We all have certain frames
that which we approach this,
and we all need
to find ways that
are going to help us
get to the right answer.
What that truth might
be or the understanding
that truth may be murkier
than we would like to believe.
So we begin to look at this
selective publication issue.
I'm going to now just pivot
back to the reporting issue,
for example, because I'm
talking about data sharing.
Actually, as I think about it, I
should have gotten to this part
first.
Because even before you get to
data sharing, the question is,
are you telling
anybody what you found?
Because for people who
are non-scientists,
this becomes important
because if I'm
the most conscientious physician
and when you come and see me
and you've got a problem,
what I'm going to do
is make sure I
scour the literature
to understand what's good and
bad about particular strategies
for you.
If people have
systematically not put
information in the
literature, I'm
going to have a biased view
of what's known, right?
Because a lot of what's
known to some people
is not being aired generally.
And so I'm in a
position of weakness
with regard to being
able to understand that.
People have been talking
about this for a while--
I don't know-- for
a while in my field.
It was 1990 but
Ian Chalmers starts
writing about this issue,
about under-reporting research.
I think I'm going to go--
this is-- so one of the
ways that we developed
to try to at least even
understand this problem was,
we started requiring people
to register their trials.
They wanted to get published
in, particularly a high impact
journal, you have to
have been registered.
So we can start to look
at what percent of those
that are registered and
documented as completed.
Let me just say that a lot
of people will register.
Who the heck knows
if they complete it?
They actually don't say.
So assume that some of the
people who never fill out
that they completed the study
actually did complete it.
But if you're not
going to publish it--
I mean, they didn't go back
on to the clinicaltrials.gov
to do that.
This is what always amazes me--
the people who
actually took the time
to go back onto
clinicaltrials.gov and document
that it's completed
is a subset, right?
You've shrunk the
denominator because I mean,
the most egregious thing is
I've done this experiment
and I'm just done.
Why am I even going to go
back on the registration site
to say that we're finished?
I mean, I don't
even know why people
do that if they're not going
to try to do something with it.
But if you look at completed,
your rates are like 40%.
NIH it was low.
We started producing
these curves.
We published this in BMJ.
Percentage of studies published,
time from study completion--
we're sort of topping
out here at about 65%.
But the other thing is time.
We started realizing about
the scientific enterprise--
this, again, gets to Brian's
talk about pre-prints.
So if you've done an
experiment, tell me
how important it is
if you don't care
it takes two years to actually
get it published from the time
you're done.
I mean, if you don't
feel any time urgency--
I don't know.
How important is the finding?
And again, I'm talking
about medicine now.
Where if [INAUDIBLE] wants to
take five years telling you
he's figured out how to unlock
the secrets of the universe,
he should take his time,
because it should be beautiful
when he's done and elegant.
For us, it's like, if
we've got information
that can save lives, that can
inform choices in medicine,
I mean, we've got an imperative
to kind of get that stuff out.
But look where you are here?
I mean, this is 20 months
and we're under 30%.
40 months-- I mean,
these are huge numbers.
So this is what I wanted
to show you, is publication
of important clinical
trial results
across academic medical centers.
First, start
thinking about this.
Start saying that this
is a prominent industry.
Then we start saying,
it was writ large.
And we start talking to deans.
We went to the AAMC, the
American Association of Medical
Colleges, and
said, hey, we ought
to hold hands and
solve this problem.
And they looked
at me, like, why?
They're like, there's a
lot to do here already,
and we don't want to put
pressure on the medical schools
to do more or the same.
But I want to be
clear about these.
These are clinical trials
in clinicaltrials.gov
that were completed, and
we're asking within two years,
what percent of
them are published?
Human experiments
that-- extra funding.
And the best place is University
of Minnesota at about 55%.
You can say whatever
you want about this,
but it's all about the same.
I mean, there are a
few here at the end.
University of Nebraska
is really lagging.
I mean, Yale's here,
but I mean, we've
got nothing to brag about.
We're under 50%.
So we published this in BMJ.
I mean, I would have thought
this is a national outrage.
I mean, these are--
many are public institutions.
They're all institutions who
are taking federal dollars.
They're experimenting on people,
and they're not telling anyone.
And I want to just say something
about this word-- publication
and reporting.
Publication reporting--
what did that mean to us?
We said-- so the
clinicaltrials.gov now
has a place where you
can report results.
So it takes about 10 minutes.
You go on the site,
you say this--
they're not asking
for anything fancy.
You had an experiment.
You registered it.
What was the main finding?
So these rates represent they
neither reported nor published.
Because some people tell
me about the publishing.
Well, maybe I tried to publish.
It was hard to publish.
I kept getting rejected.
It's not my fault.
Well, I ask, how good is
your research if
two years later, you
can't get the experiment
on people published?
I mean, that's a big problem.
And you know, by the way,
we did this study on NIH.
This is about the same
rate of the NIH funding.
So of people getting NIH grants
to do experiments on people,
only about half of them
were publishing or reporting
the results within two years.
So this is very
consistent with that.
But we're saying, gee, none
of the academic institutions
are reacting, so
let's do a report card
on the academic institution.
Still haven't
gotten much reaction
and finally got NIH to
implement these guidelines
that they articulated last year.
This article helped
push that to say,
we're going to start
saying to institutions--
but what I want them
to say to institutions
is, if you're in noncompliance--
within a year you haven't
reported or
published the result,
we're going to pull NIH funding
from the whole institution.
I mean, there's just no
excuse when it's that easy
to say you're not reporting.
I mean, this is the
lowest bar possible.
This doesn't get to
anything Brian's doing,
I mean, in the sense that that's
an aspiration for much more.
This is about, are
you telling anyone
what you found because
it's corrupting
the entire scientific
literature.
And that's what I say,
guidelines, everything,
are only based on
part of the picture.
And by the way, if
you're going to tell me,
it doesn't matter
because these 50%
never deserved to be published,
that they're no good.
They shouldn't
influence anything.
We're lucky that
we're not seeing them.
Then I'm telling you that we've
got a whole lot of inefficiency
in the health care
system, and we're
placing a lot of patients at
potential risk for no reason
at all.
Because I guarantee you that
a good proportion of these
are studies that
involve some risk.
And so we've got
to rethink that.
If someone wants to make that
argument, then you want to say,
we're just wasting money,
time, and we're putting people
at risk needlessly.
This is, could we at least
acknowledge that the published
data--
that the published data
forms a classic bell curve
when swept under the rug,
which essentially means
things are missing at random.
And there have been
some studies of this.
This is one that was in the New
England Journal of Medicine.
This guy had access to
data that was at the FDA.
So he looked at all the
trials for a particular drug.
In this case, he's looking
at an antidepressant.
And he says, what percent
of the published literature
agreed with the FDA
decision and didn't agree?
And rather than go
through all this,
I'll tell you the
bottom line of this
was that the unpublished stuff
was mostly against the drug,
were negative studies.
Those were much more likely
to be swept under the rug.
So the premise of
this article was,
it's not missing at random.
The stuff that's
missing is directional,
and that's why we've got a bias.
And it makes sense, but he
had access to all of the data.
You've seen this Turner
article, I'm sure, many times.
It's like, it's just
he had access to that.
But every time we've seen this--
and it makes sense--
I mean, it's not going
to be missing at random.
It's missing in a
directional way.
I'm just going to
go through sort
of what happened with
clinicaltrials.gov
but I just kind of want
to go a little faster.
There is this issue about even
with clinicaltrials.gov, a lot
of people are registering late.
And so why is late bad?
Because you've already
started the study,
maybe even the
results are coming in,
or you're learning something,
the whole point about this
is pre-specification.
What are you going to do so we
can see at the end, did you do
what you said you
were going to do,
or were you starting to
change what you're looking at
based on what the results were?
I'm just gonna-- I know we're
kind of running late here.
And actually when they
put this results reporting
in clinicaltrials.gov,
the idea was
that people could
have a quick way
to let people know
what the findings were,
even as they were waiting
for the publication.
But studies after study are
saying people aren't doing it.
They're not taking
advantage of it.
So even though it's
mandated, it's not happening.
That's part of what
the NIH is also
starting to put into place.
But industry, if
anything, is doing better
than everyone else, and I
think most investigators
aren't even tuned into this.
It's sort of like, if you're not
reporting results after a year
that you've finished,
there's something wrong.
I mean, there's something wrong.
But overall this is really--
So what we were trying to do--
I'd say what our
contribution was--
that we started thinking--
I don't know.
We're kind of like 1/100
of what Brian's done.
You know, we started
thinking like, well, there
needs to be some solutions.
What could we, at least,
contribute to this?
It's not enough that
we're continuing
to write papers that are
describing the problem.
We need to try to think
about some solution.
So we started writing, you
know, papers about data sharing,
and we started looking
for an opportunity
to try to create a platform
that would promote it.
So the story goes
something like this.
You know, I saw that Medtronic
was getting in trouble
with one of its devices.
A group of spine
surgeons were beginning
to question the safety
of a very popular,
very highly sold device
for back surgery.
And we went to Medtronic
and we said, here
can be an opportunity for you.
If you really
believe that they're
misinterpreting the
data, why don't we
just release your data?
And you know, Medtronic
was sort of in a position
where they were preparing
to defend the complaints
and to continue to sort of parry
it and do their usual PR stuff.
And I think that we sort of
prevailed on them to say,
why not make a
partnership with us,
and let us release the data?
And we actually said, if you're
worried, let's do it like this.
Give us the data.
We'll contract with two
of the most prominent
systematic review
groups in the world.
We'll give them the
data, let them do
their report, their analysis
and interpretation of the data.
We'll do two because we believe
that it's necessary to have
two groups looking.
We'll see about
their concordance.
By the way, they didn't
exactly agree either.
That's another paper
we've just submitted,
which is trying to show
that these two world
famous groups given the same
data and the same charge
and same budget actually come
up with a little different
conclusions.
They were both
published side-by-side
in the Annals of
Internal Medicine.
Then we made the data
available broadly.
And we said to people, we were
getting paid by Medtronic,
but we had these two
independent groups,
but we were still paying
them to do analysis.
And then we said, but if
anyone doesn't believe it,
we're giving the data away so
you can repeat it yourself.
And what we were trying to
set this up so that anybody
can take a look at this.
We ended up creating the YODA
project, the Yale Open Data
Access project,
which was a platform
to try to enable people.
We thought about
industry but also others,
to be able to have a way
for their data to be shared
but it was still attendant
to the concern of the data
holders.
And the kind of concerns of
the data holders that we wanted
to attend to were, they
wanted to make sure
that these were
research questions that
were being asked, particularly
industry, not litigation, not
commercial, not competitors.
Although, lawyers
and competitors
could put in proposals, but that
wouldn't have been ostensibly
the prime motivation for it.
We would evaluate
that with science.
We'd help work with the people.
In transparency, we
would post the requests
and we would require people
to report their results.
And then we would give
them access to the data.
And on our side,
what was important
us was we were
totally independent.
Our contract with
the companies had
to say we had full
decision making power
over who got access
to the data, and they
knew that our stance was we
wanted everyone to have access.
That was, we didn't
want to be a barrier.
And so actually, we
haven't denied anyone.
There have been a few
that we passed back
because we said it's a
difficult to understand proposal
and you need to work
on it a little bit.
But not because we were
judging the science to be bad
as much as they were having
trouble articulating exactly
even what they were doing.
So we were willing
to work with them,
but we were trying to help
them to figure out what
it was that they wanted to do.
But so we created this as a way.
We start with Medtronic.
Medtronic actually peels
off it after two years,
but we were able to enlist
Johnson and Johnson.
And Johnson and Johnson
basically told us they were
committed to sharing
all their trials--
they're the largest drug and
device company in the world--
all of their drug trials, all
of their device trials-- which
was unprecedented--
and actually,
their consumer products,
so Tylenol, Listerine,
anything you're interested in.
And we have 180 of the
trials now on the Yale site.
And actually, for
anyone listening,
I've always felt
that at Yale it's
an under utilized resource.
We have 180 trials
that anybody here
could request access to to
answer a scientific question.
And then you would get--
it's held in a SaS
enclave, but you'd
be given permission to use it.
We have the metadata
about the trials.
The data is de-identified and
anyone can make use of it.
There have been many groups
that have looked at this.
Let's see.
I wanted to-- and since
we've started doing this,
a lot of the other places have--
the industry's been way
ahead of academics in doing
this, particularly GSK.
But I think that, just to
be clear, it's not our data.
So we're an independent third
party without interests,
removing perception
of influence access.
We have full jurisdiction
to make the decisions,
and we actually use public
comment to form our approach.
We wanted to see
what people said,
what they thought was
going to be important.
If you go on our site, you'll
see categories of trials.
You can go into any of them.
There's a lot of
information about it,
and then, we try to approve
requests as quickly as we can.
All we ask-- investigator name,
affiliation, co-investigators,
research proposal, including
background, study design,
main outcomes, statistical
analysis, plan,
and a COI statement.
But all of it's for really
transparency and disclosure,
and we don't dig deep
to start to-- it's not
an NIH application, where
we're trying to reject anyone.
We're just trying to do this.
And once they're approved,
people sign a DUA.
Like I said, they gain
access via mainframe
and it just basically
prevents distribution
and makes sure that we're
protecting patient privacy.
The number of requests has
been relatively modest.
I mean, we're out here, and
we have had 55 requests total.
And so we think that
the principal issue here
and the criticism
we're getting is
all of this work is
being spent on open data
access but not many people
are making use of it.
So is there really the demand?
And we think we're still early
in this, that people are still
getting used to the idea
that they can do this.
That even as we've
tried to publicize this,
I don't think enough people
know about the resource,
and we're still deeply
committed to the idea
that this is going to
yield important studies.
We had our first
couple of publications
from the data sharing.
We think presumably
we'll see a lot more,
and we're eager to sort of see.
If you go on our
site, you can see
we have public reporting
of approved requests,
submitted proposals.
This is interesting.
Some of the investigators
have been concerned that we're
sharing their request.
That this is-- they've got the
secret to the universe, which
they should share
with [INAUDIBLE],
but that this is somehow
preempting their work.
You know, we believe
that, again, this
is an opportunity for people
to both be able to collaborate
and to see what's going on.
We do try to respect
concerns, but we tell them,
we think we need to go.
And so our goals, I
think, going forward
are facilitate greater access
to clinical trial data,
increase transparency by
accelerating generation
of new knowledge, and at
the same time, promoting
responsible conduct of research.
Our whole thing
about getting people
to fill it out and post
it, we believe strongly
in pre-specification.
Even if you're doing
exploratory analysis--
this is the point I
brought up earlier--
it's OK to do
exploratory analysis.
Just say that's
what you're doing.
And so we think we can
contribute to that.
The whole goal is better
inform patients, clinicians,
and industry.
So decisions can be
based on the most
comprehensive and contemporary
evidence available relevant
to benefits and
harms of therapy.
People can now go on our
site and see all the trials
that Johnson and Johnson did.
Published or unpublished,
you can see them,
and people can make the
choices for themselves.
So we like the Yoda
theme, you know?
Try not.
Do or do not.
There is no try.
I think the point--
I don't understand what
that means but the point is,
I think, for us in academia,
the responsibility is not just
to describe problems but
try to solve problems.
And in this case, if we think
that there are approaches,
we should experiment.
We should try them.
And one of my hopes, I
think, is that at Yale, we
can begin to get more of the
faculty interested in trying
to set an example about what
good science looks like--
not just good science
in terms of publication
and high-profile places and lots
of publicity, but good science,
in terms of the way
it's done, the workings.
How we teach our students
about what that is.
What's the ethos that we have?
And how we can reflect
a lot more people
like Aaron, who maybe are
going to say that this
is about a social good.
And that we need to
have a sort of spirit
here that we're trying to
be open and transparent,
and we want others
to join us, and we
think that's in
everyone's best interest.
So thank you very much.
Let's take some
questions for Harlan.
Thank you.
Just a quick question--
do you see the setup you
have right now for YODA
as eventually being unnecessary.
So is there going to be a
point where the data could just
be released, or do you foresee
always having an intermediary,
someone who makes an approval.
I think it's really
a good question.
We have, I think,
taken the position
that we should not be thinking
about our self-perpetuation
as being one of our goals.
Now, but we do think we still
fill an important purpose.
And the question will be whether
this will all come together,
because what people
actually want to do
is be able to combine trials
across companies, too.
And so right now, J and J will
have their stuff in an enclave.
GSK has their stuff
in an enclave.
And the question
will be, can we start
to create an omnibus
system so that if I'm
pulling a trial from
three different companies,
I can actually have
a place to put them
and they're all permitting
that kind of combo.
I will tell you, J and
J is open to that now.
But it's not optimal
that YODA exists
and several others exist.
We do think that the
independence is important.
And when the companies are
kind of hiring the people
and they're their
consultants who
are deciding who gets access.
That's not ideal.
We have requested data
from some of the others,
and it's a more cumbersome
process than what we've got.
And I think if they can
move in that direction,
and academia can move, maybe
we can find some other form.
Maybe YODA goes away.
You know, it's not our vision
that it has to be the solution.
What we were trying to
do is say that there
are certain properties of
what YODA has that whatever,
you know, we get to
finally, should probably
be part of that process.
We're happy to serve
the purpose but again,
you know, being
in an institution,
we've also got some
limitations as well.
It may be that--
maybe it should, you know,
become part of the Center
for Open Science or something.
Maybe there's another
place where it ultimately
sits that becomes kind of
an independent place for it.
I don't know.
Everyone's tired at
the end of the day.
That's OK.
There's one sense
in which the 80%
is completely terrifying
about what isn't being done
with open science and medicine.
But there is
another sense where,
it seems to me, that the
breadth of work that you've done
is a illustration of
victory of open science.
Because just one
example, the rates
of reporting studies that have
been completed after 24 months,
there is no way to do that
study in preclinical or basic
sciences.
It's just not possible to do it.
We have no idea what
studies have been done.
There is no registry of
what studies are being done.
There is, even
despite, oh, my god,
there's a lot happening here.
This seems very
optimistic in that there
are ways to make it serviceable
so that you can identify it.
You can do research on the
process, figure fi ways
and improve it.
So do you see--
are you cynical or
optimistic about where--
No, really, I mean,
we're actually, I think--
to have lived through this
period, where we first
saw a problem and
no one was really
working on it in medicine, to a
point where I've got, you know,
Rob Califf, as an
FDA commissioner,
standing up and
saying open science
is the only way to
go going forward.
And Rob's kind of convert.
You know, he was running
the Duke Clinical Research
Institute and founded it.
He's a great investigator.
But you know, Rob was one of the
early people when I talked to,
was kind of, you know,
not sure about it.
And you know, what I see now
is, you go to our meetings
and you can--
where it's about the
edges now, you know?
How many months should
it be, or how much time
should we be given?
And some of the trialists are
still concerned about the work
they've put in and what they're
getting now but there's a--
we've moved at light speed.
I mean, to be able to
get this from the NIH.
To get what Gates is
saying, which is your stuff
should go right away.
To get what Cory's going
to say, which is you've
got to be able to report
your stuff rapidly,
and we expect the data to be
shared from high stakes funded
projects.
I mean, from a time when
nobody was thinking like this,
it's only about 15 years,
10 or 15 years, it's--
maybe 10 years really.
It's really a remarkable change.
So I think we're excited.
That's why we're excited
to work with you, too.
I mean, we think there are
other frontiers out here,
but I think we're getting there.
And I think it will be at
a point where, you know,
it'll seem to be unbelievable
that somebody would not
be reporting their information
And that's what we want.
You know, we don't want
to embarrass people.
It's not about shaming people.
We want to create
normative behaviors, where
that's just what's expected.
And that's what we're teaching.
That's what we model.
That's what we do.
And if you don't do it, there's
something wrong, you know?
Meaning that, you
know, it's an anomaly.
Something's at issue.
And we're getting closer.
So I think if you hear
impatience in my voice,
it's just because I want
to see change faster,
but in terms of progress,
it's been remarkable, really
remarkable.
Thanks.
I have a comment about some of
the non-reproducible results
in clinical trials, maybe
psychology experiments, too.
So in a lot of
these experiments,
the variability in
subjects gets reduced down
to really discrete demographic
variables like age and sex
and race, but human
biology and personality
is much more complex than that.
So in some sense, even
if you are perfectly
replicating results and you
have appropriate power based
on the variability that
you're modeling for,
you expect that there's maybe
just a ton more random error
in subjects.
And so if you accept
that, we really
have to replicate
studies multiple times,
not to validate the
results of one study
but because only through
multiple replication could
you ever come at some
kind of consensus
given variable outcomes,
that, yes, this
is a real effect or not.
So there's still important
room for open science and data
sharing in all that but
more of an incentive
actually for multiple labs
to be replicating results
and then come up with one
consensus after those studies.
I think our biggest challenge
is the cost and time that's
involved in doing any
of the single studies.
It's like, it's a big
mountain to climb.
Physicists, you know, have
the same issues, you know?
That they can't create--
Cerno creates something
big in France.
They can't create it
all over the place.
So they've got to do it right.
For us, though, there are all
these different variables.
So there's two issues
you brought up.
One is about external validity.
I mean, it's valid
for that if you
do believe the results
for that group,
is it equally valid for older
people or younger people
or people in different countries
or in different health systems?
And then there's the
issue of whether or not
there is actually internal
validity and whether or not
actually what you found in
that group could be replicated
again, and that's really--
that relationship is true.
And then you've got the
stochastic nature of it,
too, which is if you
did it enough times,
you're going to see some
distribution of effect.
Because it's likely
not deterministic,
where you give everyone this
and you give a and b happens.
It's you increase the
likelihood of a or b happening.
And so the distance
between the two groups,
even within the
same group, there's
going to be some
distribution of effect sizes
that, you know, just
by chance alone.
So I mean, that's what
makes it complicated.
But I don't know.
Brian, you've thought more
about this than anyone,
about the approach.
Because in a lot of these
cases that aren't replicated,
you've actually held constant
a lot of the other issues.
But once you start
saying whether it would--
whether when you don't see it
replicated in another group,
that represents an
interaction or it
represents a non-replication
of the initial study.
Those are two hypotheses
that have to be further,
I think, evaluated.
They're both possible.
I don't know if you have
anything, Brian, on that.
Other comments?
Thanks.
So I have questions about
the platform on data sharing
and [INAUDIBLE] of data.
So I work in VA CSP, so we
have done a lot of trials.
We have discussed this as
an internal discussion,
about data collection
procedures.
So we found that most of the
time-- well, so for example,
for defining a certain
disease, the different ICD
codes, or if you define,
for example, hypokalemia,
whether you based on lab
results or some trials
require you come back in
one or two weeks to confirm.
In that case, a
lot of details that
will affect how
the data is really
compared, whether
it's in a fair way.
So I wonder when you have
that data sharing projects,
do you have some plan to have,
for example, like protocols
or operational
manuals that will help
people to really understand
how the data is collected.
So this is an important point.
First of all, it would be great
if the VA started sharing data,
you know?
I've talked to the
top people at the VA,
and they're
philosophically aligned,
but they don't share data.
So that's an amazing
thing, you know?
The federal government
pays for trials in the VA
and the VA doesn't
share the data.
They will say you can apply to
work with VA investigators who
did this study.
By the way, this is another
interesting thing, Brian.
You know, a lot of the
things people are saying
is, well, if you
want to do sharing,
you must include
the investigators
from the original study on it.
When one of the
beliefs here is you
need to separate from the
original investigators instead.
And one of the
things that I would
hear a lot from
established investigators
were that no one
could possibly use
my trial because
they could never
understand the data like we do.
And then I would say, but
what about the documentation?
And the say, well, we
made a lot of decisions
that we never documented
and that no one
would be able to understand
all of the data definitions.
And we basically
just said, bingo.
You just said why
you've got to share data
because you basically just
said you're unauditable.
I'm not saying the VA,
but I'm just saying--
no one at the VA told me that.
I'm saying other
places, when I've
heard that, people
have said that,
and I said, that
without the self,
sort of, insight that
what they've just said
is actually something very
terrible about the quality
of the science.
But with regard to this-- yeah,
metadata has to accompany this.
And the presumption is--
what our belief
is going forward,
if you knew your data
was going to be shared,
then you would
take even more care
to make sure the manuals
and the documentation
and everything was very clear.
When it's not going
to be shared--
it was interesting
with J and J--
they know this.
It's not speaking out of school,
but a lot of their trials
were in very poor
shape with regard
to documentation and same
thing with Medtronics.
A lot of the original time
was spent going back and sort
of retrofitting like
the documentation,
not for bias but
just definitions.
They didn't even have the
stuff at their fingertips.
And what we're saying is
good science should be like,
immediately, you've got
all the data definitions.
Anyone on the team can
get their hands on it
and if you were
going to share, it's
not a big deal to kind of
pull this stuff together.
But for some reason,
we got into a habit,
where maybe because it
was never being shared
it was kind of like,
internally, there
was a lot of communication, but
that people weren't keeping up
the documentation in a way
that would make it easy.
But yeah, on our site
and with J and J,
we have to have all
that metadata in order
to make it meaningful.
You can't just share that data.
And that takes work,
especially going back.
What we want to see
is going forward,
people are anticipating this.
So that these
standards-- and this
is another area to work on.
What are the standards
of documentation
that represent best
practice for other people
to be able to use what
you've done or audit it?
And those, as far as I can see,
are not codified completely.
But yeah, it's very important.
And I look to the day when
VA will share their data.
Well, I think that right now
you can apply for that data
but I think some of the projects
I see, I think they have--
Like COURAGE trial.
You can't get your hands
on the COURAGE trial.
The investigators are
holding it so tight.
And if I'm being filmed, hi.
I know all of you.
You're holding it so tight.
It's late.
I want to thank you all.